the way I looked at our financial
situation over the years is that we were
doing everything right you know we were
making our bills every single month we
were putting money away Ben had a steady
job and I had a part-time job with his
dad and then stayed home the rest of the
time with the kids suena we had our
mortgage we had a credit card those kind
of things and that's how my parents used
money so I thought that was all the
right thing to do I really didn't think
we were on the verge of having an issue
right after that is when I was laid off
it definitely scared me to death I mean
we had just max or equity line to buy a
business so I had quit my job I didn't
know where we were gonna go or what we
were gonna do or yeah I was scared and
that's when I found Financial Peace
University and read Dave's book this is
the place where we start happening to
our money where we start aiming our
dollars at our goal when we first took
the FPU class we were I had no budget so
we had no idea where our money was going
at the end of the month it was gone and
we wait on the next month Kourt to come
in looking at the amount of debt that we
had in looking at the steps it gave me
hope because it set things up in a plan
and I'm one of those people that write a
to-do list out and when I crossed off i
get a little high every time i do it
once he could see the light at the end
of the tunnel and once he could
understand when we get to this place
where we have no debt where our house is
paid off and i'm not writing that check
every month things will be so much
lighter and so much easier once he
understood that it made a big difference
if you look at someone's checkbook you
can tell her tell where their heart is
and with me you know looking at the
checkbook in the past you know it was a
lot of it was very selfish and they used
to all reside here this one was my
favorite this one now is in the
Netherlands this was the boss 302 that
got sold it was really centered around
making myself happy and not necessarily
focusing on my family and I believe
that's really done a big 180 where you
know I think that the money is
you know central to the family and
that's changed pretty dramatically in
July we received this nice little piece
of paper from US bank stating that we
were completely debt-free we have our
house completely paid for your whole
lives are changed because your dad and
your mom are awesome the sooner you
start the sooner you're going to get out
of the bad situation and be able to
really be able to get on with your
lights and be able to improve your life
you